lugar de paz para los migrantes más
vulnerables el campo de pippa fue creado
en el 2012 por la ong lesbos solidarity
la estructura cuenta con 100 vacantes
para demandantes de asilo considerados
vulnerables debido a la presión de la
población local sin embargo el gobierno
griego ha prometido cerrar este
establecimiento lo más pronto posible
tenemos 21 menores no acompañados
tenemos una madre soltera que acaba de
llegar ayer del nuevo campo con un bebé
recién nacido y un niño pequeño tenemos
personas con discapacidad en condiciones
de salud muy graves a dónde irán juego
el ministerio de migración pretende
también cerrar antes de fin de año el
antiguo campo de karate administrado por
la municipalidad y donde viven 800
personas en su mayoría familias
vulnerables el gobierno griego quiere
juntar a todos los migrantes en un solo
campo para controlarlos mejor y de paso
dar tranquilidad a una población que
está cansada después de cinco años de
crisis migratoria el pueblo de pan y
aguda está justo frente al campo donde
están agrupando a los migrantes nosotros
nosotras - más o menos como números nos
han dejado de lado miren esto los
vecinos que conducen hasta mitilene
tienen que atravesar este desorden
costo te obligan a ver toda esta
sociedad está índice
creo que la unión europea nos ayuda
económicamente pero su objetivo es que
los mantengamos aquí pero de quién es el
gobernador de las islas del norte del
mar egeo ha decidido presionar atenas
para sacar a los migrantes de las voces
de beneficio
al comienzo eran refugiados que huían de
la guerra en siria y fueron bien
recibidos pero la población ha cambiado
son sobre todo migrantes
si eso no se detiene jamás la gente aquí
no puede más hace 5 años les fue
conocida como la isla de la solidaridad
pero el ambiente ha cambiado el gobierno
griego se ha comprometido a sacar de la
isla antes de la semana santa a los
12.000 habitantes que tenía memoria en
el momento del incendio